also ich denke die gefahr besteht und
die gefahr besteht ganz real dass wir
von vier bis fünf millionen arbeitslose
wieder haben werden das ist eine quote
zwischen 19 prozent das ist die
gigantische bedrohung unserer
gesellschaft man dafür gibt es auch
gründe wenn man allein da denkt dass
sieben millionen menschen in kurzarbeit
sind von dem mit sicherheit lich alle an
einen vollzeitarbeitsplatz zurückkehren
werden dann kennen wir alle die
ankündigungen der deutschen
großunternehmen aus der luft dort aus
der chemie vor allem aus der
automobilindustrie und deren zulieferer
da ist ja von zahlen von zwischen 5.000
und 20.000 mitarbeitern denen die
abgebaut werden müssen auch der
bankensektor ist davon erheblich
betroffen
der dritte punkt ist für mich der der
relevant ist auch ist dass wir bis ende
mai 30 prozent weniger exportiert haben
als im vorjahr und deutschland wie sie
wissen ist zur hälfte in seiner
wirtschaftsleistung vom export abhängig
und unseren größten nachbarländer in die
wir exportieren die eu-länder haben alle
einen wirtschaftseinbruch in der
größenordnung von 10 bis 11 12 prozent
dann wir kennen alle die verhältnisse in
amerika den usa wirken alle die
verhältnisse in brasilien kennen sie in
südostasien in afrika und indien vor
allem das in riesen außenhandels märkte
für uns wenn wir es die wegbrechen wird
natürlich die produktion wegbrechen
entsprechend die arbeitslosigkeit